hailed a hero for his staunch defense of
protestant parades David Trimble was the
tough-talking unionist who dared to
compromise I therefore give you your new
leader Mr David Timber
he led the Ulster unionist party to the
negotiating table and played a pivotal
role in The Good Friday agreement we
rise from this table knowing that the
union is stronger than it was when we
sat down other key figures in the peace
process say history will record David
trimble's great courage I think it'll
remember him as a politician who in in a
really difficult time whom we were
trying to end 30 years of violence in
spite of everything stood up and put his
name to that agreement and allowed us
bring peace to to Northern Ireland and
allowed us to progress two men who taken
a leap of faith out of the past and into
the future
their stretch for peace earned the
former unionist leader and his
nationalist counterpart John Hume the
Nobel Prize for Peace
David Trimble went on to become the
first person ever elected to the office
of first minister in Northern Ireland
but the rise of shin famed before the
IRA had decommissioned weapons required
him to take another leap of faith we've
done our bit
I'm Mr Adams
it's over to you
we've jumped
you follow
David care was David trimble's press
secretary and worked closely with him
for a decade I do believe history will
be kind to David Trimble because I think
when historians look back
objectively with a longer perspective
over the time frame of of things that
happened before and after the Good Fred
agreement I think they will understand
the pivotal rule that he played in
transforming politics here
he incurred the wrath of hardliners and
eventually lost his upper bound seated
Westminster to the Democratic unionist
party
but elevated to the Lords he expressed
no regret for compromising describing
the Good Friday agreement as his
greatest achievement lawyer academic
Statesman David Trimble will be
remembered for his ability to see what
others couldn't the potential for peace
David Blevins Sky News in Belfast